stelter continued because one of the
other things that these people do is
they they are horrible at their job they
spread misinformation they accuse you of
what they are doing and then when they
get called on out on it they have to
pretend that they are the victim because
nothing is higher in the hierarchy of
lunacy than victimhood to these pathetic
buffoons so stelter here he is he's a
victim I'll tell you a brief funny maybe
not funny story so I leave CNN and
there's a crazy website that posts an
article saying I was arrested by
military police and then I have a fact
checking email and I don't know whether
to reply to the fact Checker and bother
with this right same website a month
later says I've been executed at
Guantanamo Bay so the fact Checker
emails me again and I say well do you
want to take my pulse how do I disprove
that I wasn't executed and so to me that
is that is amusing and ridiculous poor
guy he has to respond to emails about
whether
God's sakes you know I said to the guys
during the clip you know yesterday I
said that Al Gore seems to be filled
with jelly I think they're really
stuffing stelter with jelly what's
what's going on with these people the
other thing that really is bizarre about
stelter and it proves when I talk about
these people who just give the system
that they want stelter is also not
talented in any way right like he
doesn't look like he should be on
television he sounds listening to him is
quite grating right
it's like what is it about him that the
machine loves the machine loves that he
blows the machine endlessly and the
Machine like a lot of people would like
to be blown endlessly that really is
basically where we're at
there's some blow jelly thing here all
right whatever
[Music]